so with age of Ultron issue number 8 we
get this really really really cool story
where we learn what it was that it
happened after the death of Hank Pym
that had caused this reality to take
place now for those of you guys who were
unfamiliar with the idea of branch
universe theory in Marvel Comics and in
comic books as a whole I would advise
you guys to either go back and watch my
video on how alternate realities
function or to go watch Betty's video on
alternate realities and how they form
within both DC and Marvel because that's
going to be pretty important for you
guys to understand in order to really be
able to get a good grasp on how this
works but what we see as we start this
issue with is that Tony Stark has taken
the memories of both Wolverine and Susan
storm and converted them into images
something that he can physically look at
now we don't know for example how he's
able to do this but what we do know is
that whatever technology is being used
by him at this time is far more advanced
than the technology that exists in the
normal earth-616 universe indicating to
us that perhaps something took place
whereby technology had to be sped up but
what we see going on is that while Tony
Stark is analyzing these memories he's
not necessarily analyzing them on his
own of course he's using Jarvis but he's
also made these memories in the form of
images because he's enlisted the aid of
Emma Frost and Professor Charles Xavier
and what this tells us is that both of
these individuals exist within this
alternate reality now of course Emma
Frost and Charles Xavier were largely
tied to the x-men but we don't know if
the x-men even exist at this point of
course we know that Cyclops who is using
the codename Cable is a part of the
defenders which tells us that perhaps
the x-men maybe fell apart they went
away or perhaps they were never even
formed by Professor Charles Xavier and
Emma Frost all we know is that at this
point they've more or less just come
together to work for for Tony Stark
and what Tony Stark asks them is whether
or not these memories could have been
duplicated whether or not they could
have been falsely implanted perhaps by
Morgana LeFay now Morgana lafay again is
a villain that we haven't got to yet in
our discussions on this YouTube channel
but for those of you guys who are
familiar with the comic book villains
you know that Morgana lafay is not
necessarily a major villain in the sense
that she goes against a wide array of
different teams the
x-men The Avengers and so on she's
largely a villain of Doctor Doom of the
defenders and of Spider Woman but for
this story Marvel's elevated her to a
major villain but what we see Emma Frost
and Charles Xavier saying is that even
if Morgana LaFace somehow had a hand in
this there's no possible way she could
have implanted these memories into the
minds of Susan storm and when will rain
and allowed them to see two different
things at the same time and interpret
them different ways that is just not
possible and then she does have that
kind of magic if she does have that kind
of power at her disposal then perhaps
she's far more powerful than any of them
had previously thought but again Tony
Stark's a little reluctant here Tony
Stark's a little hesitant to believe
that they come from an alternate reality
but if that's the case if they do come
from an alternate reality if they do
hail from a different dimension and that
Wolverine or Susan storm or somebody had
done something to alter the course of
reality then as far as Tony Stark is
concerned they somehow managed to break
time and so again the idea here is that
the the normal I'm sorry the alternate
version of Wolverine wants to
interrogate the normal work version of
Wolverine and Tony Stark says no Tony
Stark says this is not going to happen
not only that he also tells Xavier to
send the defenders away which tells us
that maybe there's trouble in paradise
here that things are not necessarily on
a I guess a solid foundation between the
defenders and Tony Stark that maybe
there's an uneasy alliance here that
perhaps they were even coerced into
undertaking in this role in addition and
with Frost asked the question as to
whether or not she should wipe the
memories of this current event from the
minds of the defenders and what Charles
Xavier does here is he indicates to us
that while this is an alternate reality
that his mindset and his belief systems
still remain the same in the fact that
he tells Emma Frost that he doesn't like
that kind of abuse of power he doesn't
like people using their powers to
manipulate the minds of others or to use
their powers on others against their
will and so what Tony Stark does is he
tells Jarvis to pull up the security
footage from from Hank PIMs
murder
from here we switch to Wolverine and
Wolverines being interrogated by Tony
Stark so presumably this takes place
perhaps sometime after Tony Stark had
looked at the footage and what Tony
Stark tells Wolverine is that for the
longest time they had believed that Hank
Pym had been murdered by a scroll in
addition Wolverine asked Tony Stark what
it is that that happened to him why it
is that half his body is gone and what
what Tony Stark says is that at some
point in the past after the death of
Hank Pym that the Avengers had split
apart that there was a war between
Latveria the home of Doctor Doom and
Asgard the home of Thor but that after
this conflict after this this war had
taken place that Thor had vanished and
that he hadn't been seen since in
addition we learned that Morgana lafay
has conquered half of the world and most
of Europe indicating that whatever kind
of forces she has must be forces of
incredible magnitude what we also find
out is that the Avengers had broken up
after the the death of Hank Pym and that
magic it's somehow won over technology
and that Asgard in addition to Thor had
turned their back on the on the planet
Earth entirely and so as Tony Stark put
said O'Brien had completely and totally
broken the world by the actions or by
committing the action of killing Hank
Pym from here we transition to Susan
storm and Susan storm is being held in
some kind of some kind of giant square
room and she doesn't really know where
she is
she's trying to call for someone to come
in and talk to her but nobody answers
and so what she does is she uses her
powers to create force fields to somehow
make a force field within the handcuffs
that are used to bind her hands and by
using her force field she's able to
destroy these these restraints and able
to escape at this point we switched back
to Wolverine and Wolverine asks again
what it is that's going on here if he's
under arrest if he's allowed to go but
what Tony Stark asked Wolverine if it is
if he knows what the butterfly effect is
does he know what it means when one act
takes place that influences a multitude
of other acts and what wolverine says is
that he doesn't think he did anything
wrong here that hank pym created a robot
and because he created Ultron that the
world had been left to burn and so for
him he'd done the right thing here but
Tony Stark came back
is this by saying that it wasn't
necessarily a robot that it was
artificial intelligence it was a
singular mind that was designed to
capitalize on his own intelligence and
to continually improve itself then he
asked Wolverine if he ever did anything
to try to talk him out of this if he
ever tried to get him to see the error
of his ways and Wolverine says that he
tried but inevitably he knew that it
would have failed and the reason why is
because for people like Hank Pym and
Tony Stark and Reed Richards that is
some kind of a religion that once they
realized they can do something that they
can somehow engage into a new a new for
array of technology that they have to do
it that they can't not do it
and so he felt as though again killing
Hank Pym was his only option and so Tony
Stark looks at Wolverine and asked him
if he believes he's some kind of a
selfish hero that he somehow saved the
world and of course Wolverine says that
he's not necessarily proud of it but
that he thinks he did the right thing
and Tony Stark says that if Wolverine
believes that this current reality is
better than the one that Wolverine came
from then Wolverine is a fool and what
this means for the most part as far as
our interpretation goes is that even if
the even if Ultron had somehow managed
to eradicate the past even if somehow he
managed to eliminate all these forces in
the timeline that Wolverine had came
from when they jumped into the past that
there was still the possibility that
Wolverine or that Ultron could have been
stopped there was still the possibility
they could have done something to change
things but with this reality it seems as
though the world is on the brink of its
self-destruction and so there's really
no way to get out of this circumstance
from here we transition to one of the
helicarrier's along with Colonel America
Hank I'm sorry Jim Van Dyne and others
and for the most part again defenders
have band together because they want to
know what is it what it is us taking
place you want to know what's going on
here indicating that of course the
defenders are being kept in the dark by
the forces of Tony Stark and various
other individuals and they're not
necessarily previewed to the kind of
information that would normally be done
in the normal reality when we would see
that the Avengers would share
information with shield
in addition Emma Frost arrives here and
Emma Frost tells the defenders that
they've been ordered to go back to their
to their on our to their rest of
relaxation time or to do whatever it is
they do when they haven't been caught
on foreign mission what we see is that
for the most part I guess the thing Ben
Grimm wants to know what's going on with
Susan storm he wants to know why it is a
Susan storm is here he wants to know why
it is that presumably she's alive if it
is real her and again as far as
Wolverine was able to detect using his
senses it was in fact the real Susan
storm as so Ben Grimm is very confused
here in addition the defenders are very
upset at the fact that for the most part
they're being left in the dark that
they're being held out on information
that they consider to be important and
so what Ben Grimm does is he initially
goes and I guess passes by Emma Frost
and attempts to enter the Helicarrier to
find out what's taking place but Emma
Frost tries to grab him and stop him and
tell him that if she if he can continues
if he keeps moving and doing what he's
doing that she's going to revert his
mind back to a primitive state from here
Doctor Strange who appears to be the
leader of the defender steps in and says
that if Emma Frost does anything like
that that he'll use his powers on her as
she's never to touch a member of the
defenders and given the fact that she's
displayed such an arrogance against one
of his members and once the one of the
members of the defenders he tells the
thing Ben Grimm that he's okay with his
choice and that Ben Grimm can now
undergo the task of trying to find out
what's going on with with Susan storm at
this point we transitioned back to Iron
Man and to a Wolverine and again Tony
Stark is continuing to interrogate
Wolverine and what he does here is he
tells Wolverine there was another choice
that could have been made here there was
a third decision will rain had a
multitude of opportunities in front of
him but he didn't think of the most
rational one he simply just thought of
the only thing that he knew which was to
kill Hank Pym what Tony Stark says is
that he that Wolverine could have told
Hank Pym about what was going to happen
and they could have devised a
time-release virus that this virus at
the right moment could have been
activated by Hank Pym and could have
been used to kill Ultron but instead
Wolverine decided to kill Hank Pym what
we also see is that while this
interrogation is taking place that the
thing Ben Grimm and the remainder of the
defenders are breaking into the to the
Helicarrier and trying to find Susan
storm and so for the most part we see
these two situations going on at the
same time
we see that Tony Stark is for the most
part chastising Wolverine of the over
the fact that he broke time that time is
not some kind of absolute construct but
it's not some kind of absolute thing the
time has ramifications that met a
manipulating time that messing the time
can cause a lot more problems than
people had initially thought and as we
transition back to the Thames Ben Grimm
we see that of course they they appear
to be able to break into the the holding
cell containing Susan storm at this
point because the holding cell has been
broken the I guess Jarvis comes in and
tells Tony Stark that they're under
lockdown and Tony Stark begins to
realize or begins to believe that maybe
this is again some kind of trick by
Morgana LeFay and we'll find a surprise
to see that Morgana LeFay is even in the
discussion here that Morgana lafay is
considered a threat by anybody and as
the door I guess is a the defenders
hover around the door and begin to break
into it when they get in they realize
that the room is empty but Wolverine
says that Susan storm was just here that
her scent is very very strong at this
point the door slams shut behind him and
what we learn is that Susan storm was in
the room when they at first entered but
she had made herself invisible and she
had taken there the opportunity there
surprised at believing she was gone to
sneak out and then shut the door behind
her effectively leaving Cyclops the
thing and Wolverine trapped inside of
this room from here we again
transitioned back to Tony Stark and Tony
Stark has left the interrogation room of
a Wolverine and is now pursuing Susan
storm and again while he doesn't
necessarily believe this may be a
attempt by Morgana lafay to infiltrate
shield or to infiltrate what passes for
shield and this alternate reality he
does believe this Susan storm doesn't
need to be there and so the defenders go
to the aid of Susan storm to a degree
but Tony Stark is also attending to kill
Susan storm but before anybody can
really do anything in terms of their a
defense of either against or for Susan
storm there's a massive flash of light
in the sky and as the light begins to
dissipate as things begin to come into I
guess come into clarity we learn that
out of this portal in the sky come the
forces of Morgana LeFay along with an
entire host of doom
at this point the defenders jump into
action and the defenders do what they
can to try to hold off the forces of
Morgana LeFay but again for the most
part they are absolutely helpless
against such overwhelming odds but again
we see that we transition back and forth
between both the the bit the thing Ben
Graham Cyclops and Wolverine has her
trapped in the room Tony Stark as he's
trying to kill Susan storm as well as
the defenders who were fighting out and
in the open against the doombots and
Tony Stark once he arrives demands that
all of the drones at his disposal be
used to combat the forces of Morgan
Morgan le Fay
so for the most part he's abandoned this
attempt to kill Susan storm and is
trying to keep Morgan le Fay from
conquering this entire area again we see
that the defenders are trying to do what
they can to hold her off but for the
most part they're unsuccessful here due
to the fact that the doombots that she
has at her disposal are magically
enchanted given her ability to
manipulate magic and sorcery but also
because there's just so many of them and
so as as Tony Stark is battling Morgana
love Fay he tells her that he thought it
was a very interesting trick that she
had attempted to have a clone or perhaps
some kind of copy of Wolverine and Susan
storm enter the Helicarrier an attempt
to subvert them from within but Morgana
LaFace says she doesn't nobody's talking
about that she has no idea what it is
that he means when he says this but
tells him to turn around and when Tony
Stark turns around he realizes that two
of the helicarrier's are crashing into
one another and themselves crashing into
New York City below from here we're
going to bring this story to an Annan
the next issue we'll see what happens
with the fallout of this conflict when
both of these helicarriers are crashing
into the street as well as what
presumably happens between the normal
and the alternate versions of Wolverine
and how everything appears to possibly
go back to normal with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and I will catch you guys later
peace
you